[MUSIC PLAYING]
ETHAN SOMMER: Hi,
I am Ethan Sommer.
I'm a director of engineering
at Target for external cloud
and containers as a service.
And I'm going to tell you today
a little bit about Target's
journey with Kubernetes.
And Jay is going
to tell the story
about how it's gone as we've
deployed that into our stores.
So I'm going to
talk specifically
about how Target is using
Kubernetes in our data centers,
in the public cloud, and in
our stores across the country.
I'm going to talk about
how Target decided
to bet on Kubernetes and kind
of what our journey has been
in our data centers in Google
and at Google Compute Engine
and in our stores.
And I'm going to tell you kind
of what sorts of challenges
we ran into on those
different places
and what we learned as we
went through that, because I
think it's a similar story to
what most organizations would
see.
But this is how
we've experienced it.
So how did we get to using
Kubernetes in the first place?
About-- I don't know--
four or five years ago,
Target started to kind of
try to adopt DevOps and agile
practices.
And part of that was
trying to move away
from kind of a traditional
dev and ops model
and to try to empower the
development teams to do
more of the ops work.
And part of that was by
adopting config as code.
And to do that, Target
used a lot of Chef.
And Chef was great except
for all of these problems
that we had with it, right?
I mean, people used
community cookbooks
that they didn't understand,
that when they didn't work,
they didn't know
how to fix them.
They took a long
time to converge.
When we were using them
in the public cloud,
if a autoscaling
group like a node
failed and it got replaced, well
maybe one of those dependencies
had changed in the meantime.
And then it didn't work.
And people spent a huge amount
of time trying to make it work.
I think I heard some team--
you know, maybe they
were being hyperbolic--
but they estimated
that they spent
80% of their time doing
deployments and 20%
of their time actually
delivering software.
So about a little
over two years ago
we started adopting Spinnaker
and immutable deployments.
And we provided-- basically the
way that immutable deployments
work is that you provide--
we provided the
teams a base image,
which had met our
security requirements
and had some agents to do
logging and stuff like that.
And developers
created an RPM file.
And they knew exactly
what they were including.
They weren't like including
some community cookbook.
They'd install an RPM
from our operating system.
They'd install their
software, then put a config
file onto it-- maybe a
templated config file.
And the dependencies are
all resolved at build time.
And builds took like
five to 10 minutes.
But then when you
went to go spin up
a new instance of your
program, it took only a couple
of minutes.
But it was limited
to public clouds.
And it took the developer time--
the time it took
them to figure out
how to get their stuff
deployed-- from being
about a month to about a week.
And one of the biggest
problems that we had with it
was that you can't go
out and buy an O'Reilly
book about the way that we
combined all of our tools
together.
We used a lot of
HashiCorp tools.
And we still do.
This is how we do
VM deployments.
We use a lot of HashiCorp tools.
We use Spinnaker.
We use an ELK stack.
And so the way that we
combined those together
was unique to Target.
And see, we had to write
all of our own documentation
and teach hundreds of
thousands of developers
how to use this stack.
Oh, and it was limited
to public clouds
until Target added OpenStack
support to Spinnaker along
with Veritas.
We added support to Spinnaker,
which is now anyone can use.
So now you could use
it in the public cloud
and in the private cloud.
So Kubernetes-- why did
we start using Kubernetes?
Well, we only provided
the Spinnaker experience
to our non-commerce digital
clouds using public--
digital teams using
public clouds.
So only a fairly
small percentage
of Target's developers
were able to use Spinnaker
in this immutable deployments.
And so I actually
got up, because I was
leading that team at the time.
And I gave a presentation
to everyone and anyone
who wanted to go in our
technology organization.
Hundreds of people came.
And I explained
what we were doing.
And they said,
when can I use it?
And I said, I don't know.
And so we started
working on making it
so that we could do the--
deploy into our
OpenStack environment
using Spinnaker to
give it to them.
But the other thing
that we did was we
started standing up
Kubernetes in our data center.
And that turned out to be
possibly an even bigger kind
of change in how
people got stuff
out there than our
OpenStack Spinnaker work.
So in the data
centers developers
found the experience of using
Kubernetes just irresistible.
It was so much better than
what they were doing with Chef,
at least based on
how they'd been
trained on how to use Chef.
I'm not trying to knock Chef.
But the people just found that
they were able to-- instead
of spending 80% of their
time as some people said
working on
deployments, it became
something they spent a
couple hours setting up.
And then they basically didn't
think about it after that.
They just checked
their stuff in to get.
And it wound up in Kubernetes.
And they could move on
and start paying attention
to making their
application work.
And even as we were struggling--
the team that manages
Kubernetes at Target--
with some performance
problems, which
I'll talk about in
a little bit, they
were still willing
to put up with it,
because it made their
job that much better.
Application teams were
much more likely to build
resilient applications
too because of the kind
of constructs that
Kubernetes has.
Application teams were steered
towards building things
where we told them,
hey, you know that each
pod you put out there?
Just assume that it might
get killed at anytime, right?
Make sure all your
stuff is stateless.
And as a result in comparison
to our OpenStack environment,
where I think that
people generally
thought of things as living
there until they didn't
unless something went
wrong, we told them, just
assume it's going to die.
And as a result they
built better applications.
And eventually we worked
out the performance problems
more or less.
And everyone lived
happily ever after.
But I've got a few more details.
So here's an actual
quote from a developer.
He said that "Kubernetes
terrifies me, to be honest.
Getting things
running on Minikube
took so little time and
energy that I don't feel
like I learned much about it.
Am I crazy to have this
fear that it works?
I have no idea why.
What happens when
it doesn't work?"
And so that just
kind of shows that
like when people
worked with Chef,
it took them a long time to--
or before that, it took them a
long time to get stuff working.
And so they felt like they kind
of understood how it worked.
And with Kubernetes they
followed our directions.
Or they bought an O'Reilly book.
And they've follow
those directions.
And when they followed the
directions, it just worked.
So Kubernetes in
our data centers--
so what challenges did we have?
We had problems with
ingress scaling.
I mean one of the
things that we ran into
was that as we were growing--
like everything
worked great before we
had any applications using it.
And then we would start
running into problems when we
had 20 applications using it.
And then we'd go and
fix those problems.
And then we'd have problems when
we had 50 applications or 200
applications.
And you know a lot of those
things come from things
like there were
performance problems.
Some of them-- we've been
doing Kubernetes for a while.
Some of them have been fixed in
newer versions of Kubernetes.
Some of them are just kind
of inherent to the idea that
like if you use the
NGINX Ingress Controller
if you have thousands of pods
that are dynamically changing
every time it does that, there's
a 20,000 line config file
that NGINX needs to reload.
And NGINX doesn't
handle that perfectly.
And so we've been
going through and kind
of addressing these
issues as they came up.
That's enough for that.
So here are some stats about
Target's use of Kubernetes
in our data centers.
We have-- as of when I pulled
this a week or two ago--
in our test clusters
in the data centers,
we have about 350
different application teams
deploying into Kubernetes.
We've got about
4,000 pods running.
And it's not doing a
whole lot of traffic--
about 260 requests per second.
In the production
clusters, there
aren't quite as
many applications
as some of the
application teams haven't
gotten to production yet--
about the same number of pods.
And the reason for that
is that things are kind of
at a larger scale in prod.
But maybe in test, teams
have multiple different
environments.
They might have
dev and stage or--
and a perf test
environment and whatever.
And the number of
requests per second
is higher, not as high as in
some of our other environments
though.
So we run Kubernetes on GCP.
In fact, one of our--
someone on our account
team told me the other day
that Target is actually the
largest user of Kubernetes
on GCP who is not using GKE.
And I'll explain a little
bit why we're not using GKE.
But given that we're
here, it probably
doesn't surprise you that we're
running Kubernetes on Google
at all.
So some stats about Kubernetes
running on Google Compute--
we've only got 44 applications
there and 35 in prod.
And we've got about 1,000 pods.
But we handle a lot
more volume there.
And we use autoscaling
pretty well within that.
We've got about--
much of Target.com
was running on Kubernetes last
year through our peak season.
And we had a peak of
about 30,000 requests
per second going into
those Kubernetes clusters.
And we're more
like 8,000 requests
per second on a typical day
now with kind of organic growth
and whatever since then.
So what sorts of problems
did we run into in GCP?
So there were some interesting
things that we ran into.
We still have the same
sorts of ingress problems
when we're talking from
VMs into Kubernetes.
When we're talking from our
external load balancers--
so like a customer with a
web browser talking to us--
then we can use the
Kubernetes integration
with the Google load balancers.
And all of those
problems go away.
But on the inside, we are
using ingress controllers.
And we ran into the
same sorts of problems
we had in the data center.
And similarly, we can do a
great job of failing over
between regions on the outside.
On the inside, some
of the Google tools,
at least when we
started, were lacking
to make that easy to do.
So why not use GKE?
So to be clear, I wrote this
slide before this conference.
And so back in 2017
when we started,
the role-based access
control within GKE
didn't have the
features that we needed
it to have to meet Target's
security requirements.
And we told our
account team that.
And they're like, oh, we really
want to make this better.
But we went ahead, because
we'd already been doing it
in the data center.
And that's kind of my
second point, right?
We have to have an
on-prem solution.
So we have to make a
distribution of Kubernetes that
works, that integrates well
with Target's systems, that
does all of these things.
And we have to do it
in the data center.
And we use these
immutable deployments,
where we make an RPM.
And then we bake an image.
And then we put-- we do
that in the data center.
And we do that in Google.
So it was pretty easy for
us to do it in Google.
And so we just went ahead
and deployed the same stuff
that we were doing in the
data center into Google.
And that worked pretty well
for us particularly given
that Google as I said--
that Google actually
open-sources
all of their integrations
that they have
with Google Cloud components.
And so a lot of the things
when Google comes up and like
at Google Next last
year and they said,
GKE can like integrate
with this thing at Google.
Well, we got that too, even
though we were using GKE.
So I said I made this slide
before this conference.
Our relationship with Google has
been great when we tell them--
they keep saying, hey,
why don't you use GKE?
And we say, well,
but it's because
of this and this and this.
And one of those things--
probably the biggest one
at this point--
is, well, we need to run
something in our data center.
So we have to do that.
Well, obviously with GKE
On-Prem when I get back I'm
going to need to
go re-evaluate what
to do in our kind of
medium-term future,
whether that's something
that we want to adopt.
Now I'm going to
hand it off to Jay
to talk about our experience of
putting Kubernetes in stores.
JAY CHANDRASHEKARAN:
Hello, everyone.
I am Jay Chandrashekaran.
I work as a senior
director of technology
at Target managing
the compute services.
What I am here to talk about
is how we have implemented
compute on the edges.
Ethan talked about
how we use Kubernetes
as a compute platform of
choice both in our data centers
and in GCP.
What I plan to talk here about
is compute on the edges and
how we use Kubernetes.
Just a little context--
I just want to
understand the audience.
How many of you kind
of work for retailers?
Good.
So and I'm assuming physical
retailers too [INAUDIBLE]..
How many of you kind of trying
to solve edge compute problems?
Great.
Probably some of you
have solved it too.
But I just wanted to
understand the context.
So how I will go
about doing this is--
so I'll-- just for the folks
who are probably not from
the retail background, just a
quick level set in terms of why
we need edge compute, right?
So that's one part of it.
And then I'll give
a quick background
in terms of the
history of how we
did edge compute in the stores.
And then kind of we'll
get into the bit of detail
about how did we
actually implement
the Kubernetes across our 1,800
plus stores, 1,829 to be exact.
So why do we need
edge compute, right?
So we as Target operate
1,800 physical stores.
Just like an e-commerce
site need to run 24/7,
we need our stores to be up
and running all the time.
The store systems need to be
up and running all the time so
that guests can actually come in
and buy stuff from the stores.
If you think about it--
either it is e-commerce
or physical stores--
a guest who actually comes in
basically does the same thing.
They browse items.
They add items to the cart.
They go in.
And they do checkout.
And what that means for
a physical store is we
need to stock shelves.
So we use a handheld
device called My Device
to enable our team members to
actually stock shelves, right?
So these are productivity tools.
What I am trying to get to is
a bunch of productivity tools
that our team members use.
And many other retailers
probably know this.
Stores are distributed.
They are spread across
geography, right?
And network outages happen.
But you can't close the store
if a network outage happens.
So they need to
operate autonomous way
when such things happen.
And what that means is we
need to have the ability
to work in a disconnected
fashion, right?
So availability is a big thing.
Second part of it is
response time, right?
So we pride ourselves in
our checkout experience.
And if you take the other
side of things where our team
members work using
productivity tools,
we want really quick
response time for them
so that they are not frustrated
with the systems they use.
And if you take the
checkout example,
we use a metric
called scan to screen.
It basically says if a
cashier scans an item,
it should actually show up on
the cash register screen in 250
milliseconds, let's say.
And that's sounds great.
But if you think about
once you scan a barcode
what all things need to
happen before it actually
shows up on the screen--
it need to fetch
item information.
It need to calculate the price.
It needs to incorporate
the promotions.
It need to calculate tax before
it actually shows up there.
It all need to happen and
within 250 milliseconds.
So we probably have a
different kind of issue
to solve from a response
standpoint, right?
So those are two
reasons why we probably
need compute on the
edge, because we just
can't afford to take
the round trip back
to Cloud or to our data center.
So a bit of history--
how we operated
compute in the stores.
If you look at five years and
back, we bundle things, right?
Application developers
build things.
And they get bundled
together, tested most times
by a separate team.
There is a deployment team that
actually did the deployment.
There is a huge
orchestration around it,
because these
deployments are huge.
And their costs
[INAUDIBLE],, right?
So and that's disruptive
to the stores.
So you need to find out what's
a good time to deploy this.
And that require a whole team
of people to actually manage it.
How many other retailers
this sounds familiar?
So we were there.
So and then around 2015,
2016, 2016-ish time period--
of course, we started
embracing open source.
We have the Linux server
available in the store.
And so people were able to
start building microservices.
Great, right?
And then of course, our team
started using Chef cookbooks
to start deploying, right?
It's great.
And some other
challenges like Ethan
mentioned earlier related to
how people build cookbooks
and how it becomes complicated.
It started becoming
challenging for the teams.
They were able to deploy
it fairly successfully.
But it's more like 80%, right?
You still need to log into
a sufficient set of stores
to fix things.
It soon became
evident that teams
were spending like
sometimes up to 70%
of their developers' time
in actually fixing things
so that it will
work in the stores.
So deployment was
like a nightmare.
So we needed two things
from this, right?
So we needed immutable images.
And we needed the ability
to safely deploy them
to the store.
And what I mean by
that is we don't want
this mess about like--
when you talk about
1,800 stores we
need something that we are
guaranteed it will work.
And containers were a
great concept, right?
And it let developers do that.
It also brought in
some other benefit,
which is very profound.
We were suddenly
able to build things
once and be able to deploy in
the cloud for our e-commerce.
And then we were
able to deploy it
in the stores for
our checkout lanes.
So that was profound.
So immutable images
and then we wanted
to deploy with no downtime.
One of the things
that I really wanted
the team to be able
to accomplish was we
wanted developers
to be able to safely
deploy during daytime even.
So what that means is
no downtime, right?
So Kubernetes let
us do all that.
So great.
Then that's the reason
why we want Kubernetes.
So people agreed on that.
Now with that said,
there are challenges.
How are we going to implement
Kubernetes across 1,800 stores?
And how are you
going to manage it?
If it takes stores itself,
it's pretty small, right?
So we don't have like a vast
Compute Cloud infrastructure
there.
We have basically most of
the stores three blades
with a shared storage.
So it's not huge.
We have-- of course,
stores go offline.
So it can lose power.
It can lose network.
So it need to be able to
operate by itself in some sort
of like an autonomous fashion.
Then there are
other complications.
How are we going to--
if you do an
implementation, how are you
going to manage deployment
across 1,829 stores?
How are we able to monitor it?
How are we able to budget
the resources appropriately?
Those are all challenges.
So the team went
about solving it.
And what they did was
they built what we call
as a system called Unimatrix.
So Unimatrix acts as like
this centralized system
for developers to interact
with this fleet of Kubernetes
clusters, which
is 1,829 clusters.
And it will interact with
this fleet of 1,829 Kubernetes
clusters in an asynchronous way.
And it implemented
Kubernetes API spec.
And what that meant
for the developers
were that they can
interact with it
as if they were interacting with
a big vast Kubernetes cluster.
And at the same time--
I don't know how many people
are [INAUDIBLE] on the John
Engelman's Spinnaker talk.
We use Spinnaker for deployment.
And Spinnaker natively
supports Kubernetes.
So we didn't have to
do anything there.
It just kind of
seamlessly fit right in.
Unimatrix does
primarily two things.
It fetches the desired states
that gets applied to it.
And then it actually
distributes it off
to the fleet of
Kubernetes clusters.
And then it, at
regular intervals,
fetches back the actual state.
So that worked really well.
We could let these
Kubernetes clusters work
kind of autonomous.
But for developers kind of
acted like a single Kubernetes
cluster.
We solved the
problem of developers
being able to build stuff and
then just kind of deploy it.
And it's not as simple, right?
Like we don't build things and
just deploy it to 1,829 stores,
right?
So there are nuances around it.
So we need to build
more features, right?
So generally what
happens is developers
will build an
application or a feature
they want to deploy
to one store.
In certain cases if
it's a proof of concept,
they want to really send it
to like a subset of stores.
Our stores itself are kind
of grouped into regions.
And then we have different
format of stores--
small format, large format.
And we also have specialized
things in the stores,
like some have Starbucks, some
have liquor that they sell.
So we needed some
way to group it
so that people can
actually deploy them
to this set of groups.
So we leverage Kubernetes
namespaces to do that.
And I don't know who came up--
which developer came
up with the concept
of using animal names-- but
they actually use animal names
to group stores.
So beetle is one store.
It's exactly one store,
probably a store in Minneapolis,
Coon Rapids store.
And if it is
[INAUDIBLE] 299 stores.
So and what in essence happens
is we store, of course,
these namespaces' desired
states at HQ, right,
at the central system.
The beauty about this is
stores can go and of course,
work autonomously.
And if it goes down,
it can come back up
and gets the desired state.
And it will eventually
kind of get into that state
it need to be.
The magical thing is if
you build a new store,
we just need to add
it to the group.
It will automatically
start working.
It will identify which
applications it need to run.
It will download them.
It will run it.
You don't need to do anything.
It's almost like magic.
So we solved that problem of
building groups and providing
developers that ability to run
applications in these groups,
so to speak.
So that's where we are, right?
So this is a real snapshot
of our production Spinnaker,
where an application-- in this
case called promo engine--
being deployed to our stores.
So they deployed it to
the group called tiger,
which is a group of 600 stores.
You can actually see that
they're running [INAUDIBLE]..
And it is all green.
Promotion engine is something
that our cash registers use.
So it's pretty critical
for our stores.
Now so this is all working.
So where are we now?
So we started this
journey early last year.
And we onboarded our first
customers around peak season
last year.
Now we are in all 1,829 stores.
There are three
nodes in each store.
So 5,466 nodes are running.
We have close to 200,000
pods running in production
across our chain.
And it's growing really, right?
That's a state we are in.
So the goals we set
out to accomplish--
being able to deploy
immutable images,
being able to safely deploy--
teams can now deploy safely
software to the stores
during daytime when
the store is actually
working in a safe fashion.
And they can do it
across our chain.
That's story of
Kubernetes in stores.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Come on in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]